all right John just in case you haven't
had a rageful enough conversation you'll
be surprised at this next girl this is
gonna be fun i'm looking forward today
so last week there was the trailer for
metal Keir survive there was and of
course everyone who talked about video
games on twitter we all immediately jump
off and stuck giving her two cents and
I've got something this I've got
something to say am i something to say
was that I thought that the reaction to
the trailer was like the most like lame
ass Hideo Kojima fanboy reaction to what
is like I like sure like they're making
a zombie game and a lot of people
disagree to me that like this is them
you know doing what they shouldn't do
with this franchise I thought actually
if they're going to do anything with us
would kajima gone Konami are then this
is probably what they should be doing
and but I you know you guys are fans of
the series this is a good time to sort
of have this conversation the two-point
Wegg this chinwag if you will could you
go to get me to go and because what we
had a little bit of a back and forth on
Twitter about it so this little yeah
let's I guess I want to where do you
come from one is what was your initial
feeling when you saw the trailer for
Medicare surprise not surprised okay um
interested in so much as I think there's
a very solid gameplay foundation that
there there be able to pull from now
granted the whole idea of like co-op you
can kind of like see it in the online
thing but don't know how it's going to
translate into single player um curious
but but also being someone who is a fan
of Hideo Kojima's work specifically
Metal Gear like it's not like everything
he does i love right but i really like
what he's done with that series what he
did with that serious and then
understanding how Konami treated him and
how they regard the series in general
right and money and consoles and games
on consoles versus mobile and pachinko
it seems to me to be sort of a soulless
move that may not be a disaster right
right but i think it's it's fair to feel
it's fair to
to feel weird about it mm-hmm I think
that's okay because this isn't like
kojima is making a spin-off right you
know this isn't like his his his
executive producer is making a spinoff I
mean this is clearly a game that is like
I mean it's even using the setting of
his last game as the basis for the the
story so I think that's a part of it
where I felt like people were being a
bit contrarian where like if you were if
had there's a version does universe
somewhere right where this game was made
by Hideo Kojima right and then people I
feel like would have been like falling
all over for that I think the reaction
for this like all the negative the
thumbs down many of which will be on
this video is what I'm sure all alike
people you know berating it and saying
oh it's a boring zombie game and all
this sort of stuff that if this was like
a revengeance or if this was like you
know any one of the other spin-offs that
people would have been like oh no ok
that's cool let's let's give it a shot
and I feel like people are get allowance
to like this game to be good I don't
think there's anything that they could
have announced when people would have
been right behind this this is awesome
this is the metal give like no kid
kojima's gone like there I don't think
that there is a reality where someone's
like the next game is something that I'm
looking forward to but I think that's
part of like that's that's fine like
they can really do whatever they want
and I you can't give up on metal gear if
your Co not me like this is a franchise
that makes money hmm so to dress both
your points in an alternate dimension
where at a Okajima made this game that
would be an alternate dimension where
Kojima does not base games around very
very strong characters who represents
something like pretty big and meaningful
to the world around them this game has a
bunch of blank faces that are cookie
cutter like custom character
customization things go right right
enjoy the character it's you yeah I mean
I don't spoil anything for any never
mind everyone uh but to your point
though I you know as someone who is
maybe among the upper echelon of
devotees like you know I really like his
stuff I buy a lot of like mellow your
merchandise and [ __ ] cuz i just love it
um to get the hand do you have like an
arm that no you know i have the small
one but they do sell the big one there
don't want at the store in san francisco
and i won't i want to buy it to put the
ghost from Destiny's that figure in his
head just for that
back to your planet I would I would
absolutely love it if Kaname had the
gall to say we are going to tell a side
story based on a character that we've
only learned a fraction of what we've
learned of big boss in solids and I
think there are a lot of fans who would
appreciate that they at least are
putting an effort to fleshing out the
universe in a certain way this is
introducing a few things that doesn't
really add to the series and I think for
the majority of people metal gear is way
more than a gameplay see and that's an
interesting sort of that's where we felt
like we kind of had a hitter like our
maybe crux of our disagreement last week
was that like for me like I don't care
about the story in these games really
whatsoever there just like something
interesting that's happening some
weird-ass anime [ __ ] that's going on
while I'm going around killing people
right like even like I guess in my guy
saw it too i probably felt the most
engaged but like for was kind of where I
was like I'm not really on with it
actually not staying really know I know
I I aboard for and what I'll I enjoyed
it if I was that like there is clearly
likes re going on which means a lot to
like people are fans a series but I just
loved it was like oh it's an open war
game like I was you know big boss or
whatever but like so i think that like
okay can i'm you're gonna make game and
you're right like some people would like
to see like more of the story being told
i think if konami told the story without
hideo kojima that would have been way
more of a bad idea but people would have
been some people would have been pissed
that they were touching it's like
rewriting the Bible right it's like he's
not there anymore and what I kind of
feel is that like those are probably the
things that he was unbelievably good ash
that the team couldn't do it out him was
telling those stories and my creating
those characters whereas like Hideo
Kojima didn't write the netcode or like
necessarily I don't know how much input
he had into like things like controlling
and you know I'm sure he was involved at
every level he's creative director but
like surely there are people there who
are able to do those things so maybe
giving them this sort of more of a blank
slate in terms of the narrative is a
good idea or like or plays into what
they're able to do rather than what what
people want I think in some ways letting
them kind of do a fit like letting them
do a game that doesn't matter yeah
here's a game that's just going to be
fun it's we're going through a
teleporter and it
and then the next game you bring in like
sum all cheer director likes now they
can bring in somebody else after this
game well there's a success or failure
then it will probably not be critically
well received but it I think it almost
gives them the freedom to reboot metal
gear in some ways the thing is there's
so much source material that the series
has never examined in an expansive way
that I don't need someone with a
creative vision to concoct it it's there
it's waiting to be developed and I think
I would personally look sorry if you
were the director what game would you
make sounds you have an idea I'd make a
game about gray fox man everyone like
all right a lot of early years like with
interactions with other characters and a
lot of this transpired into events in
the future I think there is a very
interesting story to tell I would like
to see Mel gear rising two I would like
to see more of that story ridin is in
the fan favorite character but he's at
least a character whose story began
after the events of the rest of the
series handled by different studio
proving that you can expand upon the
universe without hideo kojima's direct
involvement there go why not try it
again right um shall we look at the poll
sure yeah but I oh yeah so we we had a
poll which was basically like asking
people whether or not they played the
game for what's how you put this
together so yes cuz yes your assertion
that people play the game for the
gameplay first and foremost yeah and I
took exception to that because i thought
it was perhaps both right so 1485 people
voted on the poll I will start with the
lowest percentage okay gameplay really
twelve percent okay the second one was
story okay twenty-one percent right
almost double and add those two together
and you get close to but not quite
thirty-nine percent which is both okay
people play the games for both so if you
look at in that regard you've got vote
for either of them you've got about I
know I don't get that you've got sixty
percent of the audience who voted on
this okay want some semblance of story
to be attached to you know a story that
they're familiar with the series that
will continue on in the next entry to
get attention that they can probably get
their shooter kicks elsewhere else but
this game provides them something that
those games don't correct right um you
may be thinking hey there are some
numbers missing I did the math and
that's not a hundred percent okay
28 people twenty-eight percent of people
played just for the butts okay I edema
does a really good job of putting butts
in his video game he does some I guess
that'll visa but that's why people are
pissed I guess that was to weed out the
jokers I mean I think haha like you just
enjoy that's what I play for that's why
Trump's on the ballot be angry that's
okay some of us just one wanna watch the
butts burn yeah I think it's safe to say
that you know metal gear as a franchise
that not everyone is into from the
get-go it was sort of niche in a
mainstream way and a lot of that is
credit to the world and the the
characters that have been established
and developed over decades so after the
fall out with Konami to treat that sort
of stuff as an afterthought and make the
gameplay that you know the icon that
you're going for I can understand why
people are perhaps having a negative
reaction right I think a lot of those
people and myself believe this game
could be fun but it's also fair to tabaq
at the concept of it okay so i will i
will contest or i will sorry i won't
contest' i will admit defeat on the
point of clearly there are a lot more
people who play this game who care about
the story than i was thinking so then
these are my followers to this so i
right so they're probably business it's
probably skewed and the end just people
who are willing to vote on any video
game pole are going to be bit more core
than regular folks but like then also or
i think you can maybe what what sort of
I don't know was that the final nail in
the coffin for its release was the fact
that not only is this a bunch of people
who probably play a lot of games and
don't necessarily care about the
gameplay just on its own but then also
the two things that we get from this
trailer even though i think the trailer
is like fine but at the end of the day
the house would survive in it which is
like already associated with like I
don't know every game on steam and like
so many like so many games are right
there and betas and office and then it
has zombies which have long been Oh
Danny they're not zombies Konami said up
and down oh these aren't zombies what
are they like oh no I get the affected
yeah yeah there cannot rise but you have
hordes let's say y al vey I coming after
you H which you know again people often
associate with this liked right overly
done game
connick like an easy mechanic I guys in
sassy and it has metal gear attached to
it right I mean Konami could have made
this any game okay yeah they could've
just call it survive yeah you know but
if they were going by your poll they
would have been much better served by
calling it butts butts story and
gameplay just the butts that should be a
go it's interesting I just it's like I
it's crazy that game was announced and
like usually it's impossible to remove a
game from the story of the game that
happened before but like so much of the
response to this is based so much on
what has happened previously which I
guess people love you too Kojima I look
at the Okajima and what happened the
Konami seems like it was real shitty
from what we have learned and the way
they treat the employees seem to be
pretty shitty from what we learned as
well yeah and but it was just it yeah i
don't know i was like taken aback by the
response but it's kind of the same story
with metroid i mean i don't have to pay
a lot of attention to like the nintendo
scene but people are very upset about
Metroid Prime Federation forstman's
personality well because they're making
a metroid game but they're not making
the Metro game people want it's the
first one in a long time and even then
the last one they hand it off to a
third-party studio tinkered with it too
much in terms of the character and story
so yeah I mean I think and then if you a
couple in no man's sky it's been a whole
lot of like yeah expectations reactions
kind of butting heads and it's it's been
interesting this massive ue it's like
that with any type of creative venture I
think that we tie a lot to the person
who creates something sometimes with
like Metroid there is no sole creator
metroid is just a Nintendo franchise and
they can do whatever they want so we
don't have an attachment to the person
who made it something like Metal Gear
that is Kojima or something like Harry
Potter is right JK Rowling if somebody
else writes a Harry Potter book it's not
gonna be as interesting something else
makes metal gear it's not as it's not as
metal gear yeah I want to see that
though i would i would love to see
someone try to capture what kojima does
in their own way with the characters
that have this Lord that they can rely
upon right now be fascinating on a
matrix not yet get a bunch of credit
people so I make their own little games
based on the they released the visual
novels the right drawn by ashley wood
with voiceovers on PSP those are really
those are the put all those characters
and scenarios in a new light and it was
really cool you could probably say the
same thing about revengeance in a way is
that like the team yes
I'm probably acid as well I imagine
whoever was oh yeah well write those
games were fundamentally very very
different yeah but I think Kojima was
still involved to it apart there you go
he won't be involved in this one Metal
Gear survive you call it's coming out of
survive sir I'm not evolving you survive
yeah it valves free to play Metal Gear
serve all free to play serve all it's
not gonna be a full price game finally
right that's a weird thing to say that
makes you think it's gonna turn up on
Steve in the survival section uh-uh what
have to wait and see let us know what
you think about not your survive in the
comments below and do your thumbs up
thumbs then let's see let's see those
fun